[Music]
i went into the vatican for the first
time on march 9th 1993
it was a great thrill
i have always visited my clients but to
go to vatican for a catholic
is something very important
[Music]
obviously all my friends knew that for
many years i had been managing
and when they saw me they used to call
me the banker of god
it was a witty joke of course
which alas today i'm paying in a truly
brutal way
thank you
[Music]
mia copa corruption in the vatican
[Music]
can i take it off
thank you
[Music]
yesterday until two minutes after six i
felt i was a friend of the pope
a faithful executor of the pope
fedex
then here is the pope telling me that he
no longer trusts me
[Music]
probably the pope could not have
imagined what kind of scandals such an
investigation could trigger
an acquisition of a large building in
central london is the most serious
financial scandal of the last 30 years
it's a sort of vatican gate in which
francis has decided at least apparently
he would answer to no one
it's a scandal
they've done things
that don't
towards the beginning of october 2019
there were three lines that very
subsequently said that the vatican
gender marie had carried out a series of
searches in the office of the
secretariat of state
being the office closest to the pope we
could tell that an earth-shaking
investigation had begun
that obviously such an action couldn't
happen decided in the vatican without
the endorsement and approval of pope
francis
it was the internal auditor who said
there was a bad thing here
he came to me
and i asked him
if he was
he showed me the numbers and asked me
what he should do
there is vatican justice
go and report it to the promoter of
justice
the promoter of justice asked me for
permission to the searches
[Music]
what we are going to tell you is a story
set in the operational heart of the
vatican
the ministry closest to the pope the
secretariat of state
that goes all the way to switzerland
to clarify this intricate story we
decided to resort to fictional
reconstructions with actors
[Music]
it is an investigation that sees at the
center of a handful of financers and
senior pre-lights suspected by the
vatican justice of having implemented a
criminal plan aimed at plundering the
vatican alcovers
[Music]
i received a phone call from the
secretary of state monsignor angelo
bichu wanted to speak to me
to entrust me with a particular task
he told me i have a very dear friend who
owns a right to an oil field in angola
in angola
at the time there was talk of the
largest oil field ever discovered in
africa
about 180 000 barrels a day
something huge
extractions for 25 years
they asked me for an opinion for me it
was an absolute novelty because i have
always been involved in finance
in countries
the trustee is a central figure in this
investigation that for months has
captured the interest of the major
national newspapers
and once again it casts a bad light on
the financial center of casino
for over 20 years crusoe has been the
external fund manager of the secretariat
of state on behalf of several banks
most recently for credit suisse in 2014
he moved from rome to lugano to open his
own trust company
the former banker agreed to tell us in a
long interview his side of the story
this is a trust certificate some golf
cups here and there
i won a rotary cup
the story began in 2013 when monsignor
pichu contacted him for an investment in
the oil sector
you had to assess the value of this deal
but was an investment in the oil
ethically sustainable
that's a good question however
for me
if an institution has an investment
proposal i assume that on their part
this aspect has already been taken into
consideration
how much was the vatican supposed to
invest
they talked about 200 million dollars
the creator of this investment at the
time held the position of substitute for
general affairs that is the deputy of
the head of the secretariat of state
cardinal parolin
he was the third of the vatican
hierarchy
[Music]
the secretariat of state has a treasury
of 650 million euros which derives in
part from a fund called the paul's sixth
fund
for a third and the other two thirds
from the fund of peter's pence
peter's pins which is worth around 400
million euros is instead deriving from
all the charity that is given directly
to the pontiff by the faithful from all
over the world
the secretariat of state should use the
money from peter's pence to provide
charity for the poorest also for the
management of the universal church
peter's pence is truly as if it were a
huge elms box inside a church
it's sort of an atm
this is a very important availability
because it allows you to always have
fresh money to invest
not initially subjected to a control
constrained by the ior
and it is precisely part of the money
from the peter's pence the result of the
offerings of the faithful to the pope
bound to support the church and the
poorest of the poor
that by the will of the cardinal issue
was to be invested in an oil well in
angola
for the purple magistrates this is the
first crime hypothesized
using funds tied to charitable works for
speculative investment
an accusation that also affected enrico
crosso who allegedly helped the
secretariat of state to disguise the
real origin of the money
borrowing the sum to be invested from
the banks and pledging the money from
the peter's pens
[Music]
this was the money that was to be used
for charity
but they didn't tell the asset managers
that they were for charity i did not
know that the banks were told to be
careful with the money they got that it
could only be managed for charity
no
because otherwise the banks wouldn't
have done any operation
why are you asking me this question
[Music]
has to verify the feasibility of the
deal
but since he had no experience in the
oil sector he started looking for an
expert
[Music]
i told him your excellency my experience
is financial i can simply give you a
hand but regarding the technical part i
have to tell you that i will contact my
bank
he said yes
act very discreetly we don't have to do
it if it can be done
if it's interesting and there are all
the criteria we'll do it
otherwise we
don't ultimately
[Music]
i pointed out that i would go to the
bank i worked with so credit suisse
advised me to go to london where i was
introduced to the mincioni group and
they were experts
[Music]
a new mysterious character materialized
in the vatican
an international financer of italian
origins who operated in london milan and
luxembourg
you met rafael michonne for the first
time in london what was your impression
about him
he seemed expert
he told me that he came from a family
failure
his father had some difficulties
he moved to london and from there he set
up his company
he boasted about friendships with the
eni group
the bank was doing transaction with him
in london
in the sense that
if whoever presented him to me trusts
him
i did
once they received the approval of
cardinal angelo
and enrique
set to work to assess the technical and
financial feasibility of the investment
meanwhile the 200 million envisaged for
the investment were promptly transferred
to a fund owned by rafael michonne
but after a year of studies and
appraisals the two financers presented a
negative opinion and advice against the
deal
took note and spread his arms
everything ended there because then the
operation was not done
[Music]
there is a lot of unrest in the
secretariat of state today
it's june 7 2013 and a report has just
arrived from lugano that casts a dark
shadow on the figure of rafael rincon
[Music]
the article reports that some italian
deputies after an attempt by the
financer to take over the banca popolare
di milano presented parliamentary
inquiries to complain about the opacity
of the financial flows of his company
and the difficulty of justifying the
origin of his financial resources
[Music]
is it possible that no one in
secretariat has investigated about these
suspicions
i wanted to know your position on the
vatican case mr tirabatic
i abide by my professional duty since
i'm still an official of the holy see i
cannot give interviews
however the judicial documents show that
the relationship between the secretary
of state and rafael michonne despite
these heavy shadows has even
strengthened
did the contact between raphael
and the secretary of the state remain
yes a contact had been established and
therefore his skill ability if you will
was to acquire the customer's trust
and he did acquire it
he proposed another investment
and they accepted
we are in july 2014
a central moment in the story when the
secretariat of state decides to
definitively abandon the idea of
investing in the oil well in angola and
turns its interest to another business
[Music]
it was proposed by rafael michonne the
purchase of a building in london
department store owned by one of his
companies the project was immediately
endorsed by farvizo tiravasi and
monsignor pulaska
[Music]
the building purchase was presented as a
very convenient investment the logic was
they were paying for something far below
its market value it was 30 to 40 below
what they could have achieved
or with the sale or even with the
renovation
because there was a kind of planning
permission that allowed the elevation
and construction
it will become a major real estate
investment
it's a beautiful building the old heroes
department store in london
a trophy asset as they call it
and so the parties agreed on how to
invest the 200 million dollars that the
secretary of state had already entrusted
to rafael and that had flowed into his
athena investment fund
100 million dollars were allocated to
purchase 45 of the shares in the london
building owned by the mission
while the rest was invested in financial
instruments of the same athena fund
they were not owners of the building but
of shares and funds
the arrangements were that the other
liquidity was to be invested in agreed
financial instruments
as an asset manager and used them
so the vatican was not directly the
owner of the building but only of shares
of funds
according to the magistrates michonne
also generated a huge loss for the holy
see by investing the remaining 100
million in financial instruments of
companies related to himself or in any
case
in speculative and illiquid financial
instruments
keep in mind that the financial markets
after 2008 have always gone up
so the liquidity part if managed
scrumptiously most likely the returns
would have been higher than the
management fees
but instead the athena fund was deep in
the red burning 18 million euros in five
years as reported by the calculations of
the petrol judiciary but not only that
to carry out these operations that led
to the economic disaster rafale michelle
is fun would have built the secretary of
state another 18 million euros in
commissions
he's not here
what time is he coming
he's not coming he's not here
but does
[Music]
this is where the financer officially
resides but we only came across one of
his servants no trace of him
no he has been here in recent months due
to corona virus
[Music]
[Music]
the financier moreover has major
interest in switzerland
not only because this is where some of
his companies are based but also because
he is co-owner of the legendary hotel
palace in sydney
we would therefore have liked to know
his side of the story especially since
the investigators point to michonne
himself as the person who most would
have taken advantage of the london
misadventure of the holy see on the
phone we reach his housekeeper
explain to him that if he gives me an
interview it will be much better
he can tell me what his position is
it turns out he's deviated so many
millions
i know it's public knowledge for god's
sake
these sums escape ordinary mortals often
the difficulty i have in telling it to
the readers is this
if we see the derivations that this
money took
we can figure out how much not only the
will of the donors was betrayed but also
the very will of the pope
but the goal of the pope is to recover
the money and punish the culprits within
the holy seed
[Music]
it was may 2018 when something bizarre
happened
the pope elevated archbishop angelo
bichu
to the rank of cardinal and appointed
him prefect of the congregation for the
cause of the saints
it might seem like a promotion but in
reality as many people say in the
vatican the only purpose of the gesture
was to distance angelo bichu from the
leadership of the secretary of state
in fact in the vatican there was already
a growing embarrassment for the
situation that had come to about this
investment in great loss and there was
no agreement on what to do
i'm calling you because i wanted to ask
you for your stance for an interview
we would have liked to know from the
person concerned why he wanted to invest
precisely the money offered to the
pontiff by the faithful for such an
obscure and speculative business
but his eminence declined any comment
doesn't he want to comment
for me one thing they should do i said
this in february 2017 was to get
reimbursed find a solution
they didn't
aiming however to buy the entire
building in london
by which they already owned 45 of the
shares
but they did not find an agreement with
the financer
and it is at this moment that a new
actor enters a scene in our
also from london another broker of
italian origins
mr torzi has approached to solve a
problem that certainly the secretariat
of state had at the time
it was also a rather pressing problem
trying to find a way that could somehow
liquidate pass me the term mr michonne
and allow the secretary of state to
regain ownership of the property
was almost fatally identified for a
number of reasons
apart from his own professional skills
above all he knew mr michonne
percy was presented as a solution to get
out of the deal
that he was the one who could be able to
convince michonne to give up the
building
he said
whom he knew very well could not say no
to him but the business relationship
they had and that he sometimes financed
with his companies
however i was a little skeptical about
the fact that torsi financed michonne
on some
to sell the building he asked for an
appointment at the secretariat and
presented a proposal to prolaska and
tarabasi
saying i convinced minchonni
and at these prices he would be willing
to sell the building
[Music]
40 million pounds this is the sum agreed
by the two italian english financiers
and presented by torsi at the vatican
a remarkable figure that according to
the pontifical judiciary seems to be
devoid of any legal and economic
foundation
especially when you consider that the
secretariat had already paid 200 million
dollars in the fund of rafael missionary
and that the property was buried with a
mortgage of 146 million euros
in fact the vatican spent 363 million
euros on a building that rafael michonne
have purchased for less than half of
that sum six years earlier
[Music]
the 40 million are not established on an
initiative of mr tarzi
in the sense that of course the
secretary of state has also shown a
clear interest in minimizing the damage
as is obvious
evidently mr mitroni gave up a deal that
was clearly very important to him
in the face of liquidation that had to
be substantial enough to allow the
secretary of state to return imposition
of the property
were you somewhat surprised
we were a little surprised
but if the customer is happy
i was amazed at the ease in which a
solution was found in six to seven days
which i feared since january 17 2017
but who is the person who in a few days
seemed able to get the vatican out of
embarrassment
one of the last times we talked about
this because i was personally curious
luigi was happy about this
he said i was lucky because i managed to
get into environments that normally i
would never have thought of attending
[Music]
jane luigi grew up in gullion
a small town in males
and attended school for agriculture
[Music]
[Applause]
his father enrico had a cereal warehouse
and they produced fertilizers
[Music]
yes
and he created another company in the
water purification sector
what about the two companies today
nothing
both went bankrupt
because unfortunately
luigi in order to do things
to reach his goals has complicated the
life of his family
making debts which then lead to
bankruptcy
from fertilizers
passing through various family failures
this is how jane luigi throws his career
started and lead him to london in the
heart of the city
he is not the classic italian of a small
town who goes to london and starts to
work as a dishwasher he went there with
a company ready to operate on the
markets
to make a leave like that from a small
town in males
from producing fertilizers to managing
international funds
you don't get there because you're good
at
[Music]
it has a very strong group of this
community
most likely the connections to the
vatican comes directly
from communion and liberation
also because one of those involved was
very very close to the communion and
liberation
[Music]
the entrepreneur
thus arrived on the doorstep of the holy
see to resolve the dispute over the
london building
at the time of his appointment
this controversial manager was already
burdened by a legal situation with
disturbing outlines in police
we are talking about jane luigi
whoa
who did to us in action
let's say fraudulent
to use the right words
at first
he approached
and the land
the financer brought the capital
the villa had a commercial value of one
million and three hundred thousand euros
to do things in a regular manner so to
speak according to his mentality which
was all the game
and had a whole thread he said we would
do a quote-unquote fictitious bill of
sale
when we put the sale price of the
property at 320 000 euro
so we'd also pay less taxes
after that we'll start building and do
everything
and this was basically our downfall
actually the company in which this
family jewel ended up is owned by torsi
and not by marcelo connechonne
the village did not obtain the building
permit and was never built
we saw ourselves practically ousted from
our property
cozy
we filed a complaint with the financial
police i showed him i suffered a scam
the officer turned around looked at me
and said
mr kona
do you
and he showed me a pile of folders 60 to
70 centimeters tall on a desk
that the officer told me very seriously
that is jen luigi torsi
since then the family has been demanding
justice
and they're not alone
in fact there are many open proceedings
against the entrepreneur
some even prior to his entry into the
vatican apparently the justice is
pressing him for a multitude of crime in
rome milan
where in december 2020 there was a first
hearing for an issue always linked to
the veronese family
his crimes range from possession of
stolen goods to the arbitrary exercise
of one's own reasons invasion of other
people's land and there is also the
crime of aiding and abetting
what did you decide to do
i suddenly came to write to the pope to
briefly describe our situation
do you want to read what you wrote
[Music]
arrived at the right time
and we found ourselves stripped of
everything we had without realizing it
because everything was masked by
affectionate concerns
a fraternal hand offered to us out of a
difficult economic situation
over time we realized an already
existing theorem
shady to say the least
[Music]
it is boxing day 2018 when something
extraordinary happens
the pope grants a private audience to
jane luigi tours
i don't know what they said but for sure
this meeting is a central piece to
understand the dynamics of the facts
apparently someone very close to the
pope presented the financer to him as
the savior of the lyndon building
[Music]
a catholic visited the holy father who
represents the highest religious
authority in the world for those who are
catholics
religious
you know that this afternoon i have to
go to the vatican to the holy father
i said congratulations but i don't know
whether i should go
what do you mean you don't know where
you should go i mean it's such a
what
nice
you say do you advise me to go
can we say that mr torzi had become
untouchable within the vatican
no let's say he solved one problem but
created another one
right
in fact the building instead of going
directly from rafael michonne's athena
to the vatican ended up in a company
owned by jen luigi torsi
the agreement was that in the meantime
the secretary of state would create a
special company for the london building
and then the police broker would sell
the shares but this did not happen
when they got this contract they
realized that a thousand shares the
voting share remain at tarzi
i didn't even know it
that is the shares with the right to
vote
and so the vatican couldn't do anything
with this building
it was the owner but in fact who managed
it who had the right to vote if you're
asking me if he could have sold it next
day for 10 million pounds
in your opinion realized that it was
buying a building to which it had no
right
no no
i totally excluded
[Music]
and after a while he said listen what
are these thousand shares
do we have no right to vote
when they read it they saw it
i've never seen this contract either
we're on our way we're taking the next
exit
yet in the holy see there are those who
argue that the terms of the contract
were well known
okay
the contract they signed with torsi
doesn't make any sense
i saw it
it was written in black and white that
the shares all the shares with voting
rights would go to torzie
while the holy see took those without
the right to vote
there are two things either someone was
too naive or they were in bad faith and
took a lot of money
if you are not able to understand the
contract you go see a lawyer right
now
but no they just signed it
in november it is november 2018.
with a new substitute for general
affairs monsignor edgar penapera
who replace angelo bichu endorsed this
operation which in a few days will prove
to be a colossal mistake
[Music]
so in fact porzi is in complete control
of this building even though he didn't
put ascent into it
when after a few weeks the vatican
decided to liquidate torsi too
but i have these shares now you must pay
me my mediation otherwise i will not
give back these shares
which in fact these shares allowed
to have the building in his hands and
thus have 200 million of the vatican in
his hands
[Music]
so we get to the epilogue the most
despicable crime hypothesized by the
magistrates the extortion against the
vatican
at first would have asked the holy see
even 20 million euros to drop after an
exhausting negotiation to 15 million
euros
i don't believe that this payment is the
result of extortion but it is a payment
that obviously can only be inherent in
an activity that was carried out the
choice was to allow the secretariat to
regain the ownership of the property and
on the other hand to allow from the
company of mr torzi through these 1 000
shares with voting rights to be able to
dispose pass me the expression of the
management of this property for five
years because mr torzi was told to get
out of this business and therefore
perhaps 15 million is a fair
compensation for something that has been
done and for what has obviously been
taken from mr torzi with respect to the
management of a property
had confined it to me that he had a
problem
because thanks to that contract poisy
felt authorized to ask for 20 million to
sell the shares with the right to vote
and leave the company
when penapera came to me i told him with
some insistence don't
[Music]
a solution for monsignor pennapera
to take the money to pay torsi from the
pope's discretionary account
an account available only to the holy
father who contrary to any logic is not
at the ior the vatican bank but in a
swiss bank
[Music]
it is right here in the center of lugano
that the office of a tesino trustee who
manages the pope's discretionary account
established in 2015 at ubs is located
and it is from this account
from according to monsignor palaska the
techno trustee should have withdrawn 20
million pounds to satisfy the demands of
jen luigi toys
the instructions sent to lugano were
very precise
use 12 million pounds available and ask
for an overdraft of another 8 million
of course we would have liked to meet
the tecino trustee but for reasons of
confidentiality he refused to give an
interview
so we don't know if the pontiff's
account has been affected
to an interview
according to the judiciary in those days
20 million materialized on an account of
the vatican lawyers in london
and it is with this money that jen luigi
torsi is paid with two transfers for a
total of 15 million
but euros story does not end there
the judiciary suspect that torsi did not
act alone
you saved me in operation
and i gave you the utmost confidence
because it saved my ass
[Music]
fabry give me 10 million and i'll go
what the hell do i have to tell you
it is december 19 2018.
the situation has now plummeted
in a sort of summit it held in a hotel
in milan to convince torsi to sell the 1
000 shares
but the men of the vatican no longer
trust anyone and someone records the
conversation
[Music]
even if you give me 10 million i gave
one kickback 1 million i paid him what
do you think
i have the bank transfer here i'm not
bullshitting you understand
he called me the night before and said
this is my count at the ups
what really happened he literally says
give me 8 million give me 10 million of
those i have three left because i pay
the others in bribes
you're not led to believe that's a
possible boasting that in the conflicted
handling of that moment it could be an
easy way to resolve a contrast
one fact is certain
that there is no evidence of this
vatican investigators are trying to
figure out if this money all went to
torzi or if part of this money was
actually going to officials and
monsignors inside the vatican
therefore to understand if there is an
internal corruption that somehow
explains why straight jacket contracts
have made all to the determine of
vatican and advantage of secular
financers
like
overwhelmed by the scandal of the london
building and a series of other legal
events is urgently summoned by the holy
father
the pope told me that he no longer
trusts me
because he got a report from the
magistrates that i would have committed
acts of embezzlement
i told the holy father if you no longer
trust me i give up my mandate i'll just
resign
that's it
[Music]
for yesterday the cardinal has renounced
the rights related to the cardinal 8 and
will not be able to participate in the
election of a pontiff
i do not feel corrupted
the crimes hypothesized in this
investigation are corruption
embezzlement money laundering and even
extortion and criminal association
gen luizi torsi was arrested and
imprisoned in vatican prisons for 10
days with letters regulatory to the
helvetic authorities the holy see's
prosecution office asked for the
acquisitions of the banking relations
and balances of the accountants of
cardinal bichou
monsignor
fabrizio
in the absence of a ruling at the moment
the presumption of innocence applies to
everyone
[Music]
you're mentioned as the person who would
most profit from this london building
deal
together
no not in the least
before enrique
the troubles do not come only from the
vatican
justice is also pressing him in
switzerland for business related to his
centurion investment fund
in which the secretary of state has
invested about 50 million euros another
story that has turned into a crime story
in the vatican
are times for banker of god who can only
wait for justice
it is true that i am worried but i am
not afraid i certainly feel sorry for my
children
for my grandchildren
it's something i did not expect
i hope they wouldn't remember their
grandfather in other ways
not because of this truly incredible
nonsense
it's like when you work alongside a
person you help him
and then at some point you turn around
and get a stab
that's what it feels like
[Music]
oh